my dad is just one of those really wise
he's a really Wise Guy growing up my dad
would just give me like these little
nuggets of wisdom that really just
honestly stuck with me and they just
stick with me for life and you know one
time I was dating a guy my dad didn't
really like because women right I didn't
listen shocking and I asked him I was
like Dad do you think people chain and
he just he looks at me and he says you
know people do change they get worse
over time typically so whatever trait
you see now just expect it to be worse
in 10 years are there exceptions that
change yes well in general people in
life tend to get fatter they tend to get
dumber and they don't tend to improve
themselves over time